all right i want to start today with the
coronavirus update i think it's useful
to do this
um at least once a week last week people
seem to appreciate it
and uh because i look at this stuff
every day i assume
that everybody has all the same
information i have and
we learned a long time ago when we were
kids what happens when one assumes and i
don't want to do that so
let's do the coronavirus update i have
cautiously good news
uh about cases and deaths and vaccines
and we're going to discuss the
coronavirus
variants and and let's get right into it
so first of all cases
last week i told you that after peaking
around january 11th average
daily coveted cases were down about 42
percent as of early last week and i said
at the beginning of last week
by the end of last week meaning friday
we would probably be down 50 in terms of
daily cases
from that peak on january 11th and we
reached that milestone and we have now
surpassed that milestone covid average
daily cases in the united states
are down to 110 000 still an insane
number 110 000 cases a day on average
but that's a 56 percent decline from the
peak
on january 11th so in basically four
weeks average case is down 56 percent
which puts us roughly where we were back
on november
10th and hopefully that will continue to
decline if cases continue declining at
the same rate that they have been since
january 11th we'd be down to about 48
000 cases a day by the beginning of
march it's unlikely that this will be a
straight line
decline there will be changes there will
be inflection points
but um this is a very very good piece of
news
and we will talk about how the variance
may affect these numbers now what about
deaths
we've previously mentioned at this point
everybody's probably sick of hearing me
say
death slag cases by about three to four
weeks
we would expect that if cases peak on
january 11th
deaths would be peaking and starting to
decline around
now is that happening yes it appears to
be happening
deaths hit an average peak of about 3
400 deaths per day around the middle of
january
more than a 911 every single day
the trend line sort of plateaued and it
has started to come down
and hopefully will start to come down
more
quickly as people are vaccinated
particularly
folks at highest risk of death so that
gets us to
variance and to get to variants we have
to go through
vaccines currently there are two
vaccines
approved for emergency use in the united
states
first was the pfizer vaccine then the
moderna vaccine
early concerns about
supply and delivery have been replaced
by
more cautious optimism from pfizer and
moderna about their ability to continue
delivering millions of doses per day
as many of you know i was on a sort of
on-call list for leftover doses at the
end of the day a friend of mine works at
a hospital that has a
zero waste commitment on doses and
i was able to get my first dose of the
moderna vaccine about 10 days ago from a
left overdose
from cancelled appointments and the
numbers continue to improve the u.s is
now giving out
an average of 1.46 million doses per day
remember joe biden's goal
was 1 million doses per day for 100 days
we're at 1.46 million doses per day and
on saturday and sunday the us
actually did 2 million doses each day
2 million on saturday 2 million on
sunday that is
absolutely fantastic if we get a third
vaccine approved in the next three weeks
johnson johnson has submitted their
vaccine for approval that's a one-dose
vaccine not inconceivable that the u.s
could get to
2.5 million doses per day
i mean i want to be careful but even 3
million doses per day
which would be absolutely fantastic and
the one dose nature of the jnj vaccine
makes the legit the logistics even
easier
now case is down death's starting to
come down
vaccination's starting to go up what
about
the covet variants there is a lot of
doom and gloom about the coveted
variants from the uk
from brazil and from south africa lots
of people being very dire about this
some even saying the vaccines just
flat out don't work against the variants
so what is the truth
the truth is really not that bad uh what
we know uh we know the astrazeneca
vaccine
which is not even approved in the u.s
yet really doesn't seem effective
against that
south african variant that's bad they're
having problems moving forward
okay the pfizer and moderna vaccines
which are approved in the united states
seem the way i would characterize it
colloquially
without making a mathematical statement
is the pfizer and modern vaccines appear
to be quite effective against the
variants including the south african
variant now
it is true early data suggests
you are less protected against the south
african variant
with the pfizer and modern vaccines it
doesn't mean you are unprotected
people immune responses on a bell curve
as many of you
know and we've looked at and those with
a stronger immune response to the
vaccines
are probably still protected against the
south african variant
and protect it against the british
variant that's the b117 variant and and
the brazilian variant
but very importantly this is not a
reason
not to get vaccinated it's a reason to
get vaccinated as quickly as possible
the virus mutates as it spreads
every time that the virus goes from one
person to another
is an opportunity for a mutation the
more people you get vaccinated
now fewer cases less mutation
fewer variants okay moderna and pfizer
are studying the variants they are
developing as a sort of insurance policy
a modified booster shot but that's eight
nine ten months away based on my current
understanding so
we don't yet know what the approval
process will be from an fda standpoint
for modified vaccines so what we can do
now is
there's no point in waiting if you're
eligible for a vaccine get the vaccine
because
if you prevent an infection or two
infections or three infections by being
vaccinated even if eventually
the british south south african and or
brazilian variants become the dominant
strains
the more people that have partial
protection the better there's no
argument for
delaying there is a debate now about
what happens in three months so we've
talked about
cases are coming down quickly deaths
have leveled and are starting to come
down but the variants are
spreading there are some the most
pessimistic perspective
who say the variants are going to take
over the vaccines will not work against
them
and cases will explode again to the
level we saw um
in december i don't think that's the
most likely scenario based on all of the
um
epidemiological data i've seen and
interviews and statements
and writing from immunologists and
epidemiologists
if we keep vaccinating the january 11th
peak will likely be
the final major peak as the weather
starts to improve
in the parts of the country that have uh
winter
and more and more people are vaccinated
yes it is likely true
that more and more of the cases will be
the variance
but it is also true that more and more
millions and tens of millions and
hopefully hundreds of millions of
americans
will have uh sufficient protection
against
these variants that cases will continue
to decline now
when we get to then we'll have summer et
cetera
when we get to the next flu season
in the fall um hopefully by then
there will be a modified booster if
indeed it's determined that that's
what's necessary
and my hope is and i believe it's
realistic
but cautious is that the january 11th
peak was
the final peak for this pandemic
um all we can do now is continue to be
safe
continue to vaccinate and i i've
mentioned this before
we should not undersell the vaccine i i
know people who were saying listen
i'm being told even if you get
vaccinated it may not work against the
variants
and you still have to wear a mask you
still have to social distance there are
lots of good
immunologists and epidemiologists who
are saying listen in
in a month if these the numbers continue
going this way if you are fully
vaccinated meaning a week past dose two
it's it's a very acceptable level of
risk to have an indoor dinner with six
fully vaccinated people let's be
realistic about what this means it
doesn't mean
you go to the grocery store and you say
i don't have to wear a mask because i'm
vaccinated that's going to be the policy
for some time
in parts of the country i know friends
in places like arizona are telling me
nobody's wearing a mask at the grocery
store but in much of the country that's
what's going on it'll continue to go on
but let's be realistic about
the game-changing nature of these
vaccines we'll check in about the data
again
uh next week one of our sponsors today
is
lucy and they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by caltech
scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's time to throw the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of
excellent reviews online from countless
people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get twenty percent off when you
use the coupon code
pacman and just a quick disclaimer i'm
required to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical